et à notre fiasco financier celui du
triton à centre de loisirs nautiques à
hier dans les sols triton a été fermé il
ya plusieurs années
la nouvelle municipalité vient de
racheter le site et elle espère bien le
vent et me disais il voit loin et il dit
fermé depuis six ans le centre aquatique
du triton a désormais un nouveau
propriétaire
le conseil municipal d'hier vient de
débourser des fonds nécessaires pour
racheter le bail est donc récupérer les
terres 1 1 5 million de francs pour
indemniser la société d'économie mixte
hier objectif loisirs liquidée il ya
cinq ans reste la dette à la charge des
habitants 40 millions de francs à
rembourser jusqu'en 2004 mais
aujourd'hui le nouveau maire
propriétaire du terrain espère trouver
des investisseurs
malheureusement la dette du triton a été
reconnue par la municipalité en 1991 et
on est dans l'obligation de payer cette
dette du triton ce qui est important
pour nous la nouvelle municipalité c'est
d'avoir des recettes nouvelles dans
cette ville d'où l'importance dans une
ville qui n'a pas d'emploi pas
d'activité d'avoir un tout petit peu
d'activités sous la forme d'une maison
de retraite ou d'un hôtel qui permettent
d'avoir un peu taxe professionnelle et à
terme peut-être sait-on jamais d'alléger
la pression fiscale qui pèse sur les
hyérois des habitants en guerre contre
leur feuille d'impôt scandalisé par
l'échec de ce projet 3000 d'entre eux
refuse toujours de payer l'impôt dit
triton tr/min en association de défense
ils attendent du nouveau maire qu'il
remplit sa promesse électorale régler au
plus vite cette affaire je pense que de
toute façon que ce soit ce maire ou
celui d'avant ou celui d'après il est
quand même utile de pouvoir en faire
quelque chose qui puisse au moins
bénéficié aux pour les gens de la
commune
il est certain que cet endroit à l'appel
de la plate et pour on veut quand même
faire quelque chose d'utile qui peuvent
rapporter aux lierrois déjà le fait de
payer moins d'impôts cet été le maire a
fait visiter le triton à une dizaine
d'investisseurs
il aurait reconnu que le site est très
bien placé mais tous ont été
impressionnés par l'ampleur des dégâts